thank you confident but first of all I
would like to give compliments and
express my gratitude to His Royal
Highness Prince Ali because Prince Ali
was a competitor a Challenger and he has
obtained a very good result and he in
such a situation
easy he could have said now let's go
further perhaps I would receive more
votes on the other hand ladies and
gentlemen I thank you I thank you that
you accepted me that for the next four
years I will be in command of this boat
called FIFA and we will bring it back we
will bring it back offshore and we will
brag to the beach we will bring it back
we're finally football can be played
beach soccer you can play everywhere but
we have to work on that we have to work
on that we have also to work on other
things that we have to do for free from
the future
you remember four years ago I had a lot
of problems to solve and they gave it to
you and you I challenge you at that time
I've been not going to challenge you but
we have also to make some organizational
problems inside the FIFA inside the
Executive Committee because
we must have a better representation of
the different configurations and the
number of members of a Confederations
shall have also their repercussion in
the organization of the committee and
again we need in this committee women we
need ladies we cannot just say they are
only co-opted we have to do more we have
to do more in our competitions also and
already they tell you I will not touch
the World Cup because the Val cup is too
important for Doodle doing that but for
the other competitions specially men's
under-17 and the 20 also we shall give
we shall give a second second part you
shall have a little bit more respect to
one of the Confederations that is
respected by everybody it is Oceania
they have only one member in the
executive committee they have only one
slot or as semi 50% of a slot we have to
do something for that that is not good
that is not good for the let's say for
the Solidarity in FIFA but don't touch
the ball club are you agree with you we
don't touch the ball cup but now and I
have said it before I take the
responsibility to bring back FIFA the
few we do it we do it we do it and I'm
convinced we can do it I was not now in
there in the room but I was thinking it
was in meditation I am a faithful man
and I said now God Allah or whoever is
this extraordinary whatever it is spirit
in the world that we believe we believe
they will help us to bring back this
FIFA where we shall be and I tell you
and I promise you in the end of my term
I believe this FIFA to my successor in a
very very strong strong position robust
FIFA and the good FIFA we have to
together you will ask me what what age
is not an H the H is no problem always
told you you have people they are 50
they look old it's nothing it's not if
you're sure sorry sorry sorry I didn't
know that we have so many 50 years old
people here no different definitely not
but ladies and gentlemen you know I told
you at the beginning urban and we
started for this election I like you I
like my job and I like to be with you
I'm not perfect
nobody is perfect but they will do a
good job together I'm sure so I thank
you so much I think you for the trust
and confidence trust and confidence
together we go let's go people
let's go people thank you thank you so
much
thank you thank you thank you